vous pouvez demander à n'importe qui qui est noir
et ils vous raconteront l'histoire de
quelqu'un raciste envers eux dans
l'eau
bien il n'y a pas beaucoup de surfeurs noirs
il n'y a pas beaucoup de noirs dans l'
eau
mais je n'avais aucune idée que ça allait
être autant de racisme dans l'eau
[Musique]
au lieu de simplement le supporter, nous
essayons d'influer sur le changement,
j'ai vraiment l'impression que la marée a
changé
[Musique]
les vies noires comptent
vous pensez que l'eau est ce calme
collectif
tranquille  endroit où chaque personne qui
marche sur cette terre
devrait être autorisée à être dans l'eau et
euh
juste je n'ai jamais ressenti autant de
racisme micro agression
intimidation autant que
vous le faites dans l'eau le pire qui soit
jamais arrivé est en fait appelé
le travail plusieurs  fois à plusieurs
reprises et je n'ai jamais été appelé à l'
intérieur de ma
vie jusqu'à ce qu'on me crie après
maudit après
euh et puis les hommes
sautent sur votre vague ou ils prennent votre
vague ou ils vous serpentent sur une vague parce
qu'ils  ré  Je ne pense pas que tu vas prendre
la vague parce que tu es une femme et ils
ne pensent certainement pas que tu vas
faire la vague parce que tu es une
femme noire,
ce qui est hilarant parce que la
plupart du temps je le suis  faire en sorte que
certaines personnes pensent que
l'eau leur appartient ces vagues leur
appartiennent
c'est comme si c'était ma plage ce
sont mes vagues et ce n'est pas
vous savez que vous êtes un invité sur cette planète
personne ne
possède aucune de ces merdes nous '  re tous un invité
et nous avons tous le droit d'être dans l'
eau
le groupe de blancs a attaqué environ 75
intégrationnistes lors d'une manifestation de pesée
manhattan beach
étranger
vous ne voyez pas beaucoup de gens qui
vous ressemblent
à la plage au  océan, vous savez
parce
qu'ils ont été terrorisés quand ils l'ont fait, donc
ce n'est pas comme
le pauvre stéréotype de oh les noirs ne
savent pas nager ou les noirs ne sont pas à l'
extérieur ou ils écoutent que ce n'est
tout simplement pas vrai
qu'il y avait des obstacles spécifiques mis sur notre
chemin
pour  nous empêcher de faire ce genre de
choses
et  à un certain moment, ce n'est pas par
peur que nous ne l'ayons pas fait,
c'est par survie pour l'auto-préservation,
je suggérerais que
tout le monde commence à chercher parce que, comme vous
pouvez le voir,
mon sourire grandit à mesure que je
me rapproche de la préparation  dans cette eau,
il y a quelque chose de
très curatif à ce sujet,
croyez-moi, quelqu'un qui a dû faire beaucoup de guérison à la
fois physiquement, mentalement, émotionnellement, vous
savez, spirituellement,
l'océan est là où il se trouve.
J'avais besoin de surfer pour combler le vide
que j'avais comme tu connais une vie  -changer de
blessure,
c'était super difficile, je veux dire que c'était difficile
de sortir du lit,
vous savez, puis de
sortir du lit, c'est difficile de sortir
de l'appartement,
vous savez juste d'être vu en public juste d'
être vu vous le
savez  la jambe est statique, donc ici
, vous pourrez tourner à droite à droite,
puis à partir d'ici,
vous pouvez sauter dans votre pop-up
parce que vous ne voulez pas que
ce pied revienne ici en train de
surfer et que la communauté des surfeurs
vous
y accueille  me fait me sentir bien dans
ma situation malheureuse,
c'est quelque chose que j'ai appris
tout au long de ma vie, mais les gens se
lient à travers la douleur et si vous êtes une personne
de couleur,
vous ressentez très probablement de la douleur dans une certaine
mesure
[Musique]
je pense que c'est la nature humaine pour  les gens
veulent trouver une
communauté quelque part où vous vous situez les
gens qui vous acceptent pour qui vous êtes
pensent que vous savez que vous partagez les mêmes valeurs
même mo
il y a tellement de soutien comme quand j'ai
dit que je voulais être un grand surfeur
ils étaient comme allons-y  tu t'es entraîné
tu contrôle cette voiture
rien d'autre et tu as traversé
tellement plus que moi donc tu sais comment
gérer ça
la gitane de ma mère c'était juste moi et elle
toute ma vie nous n'avions aucun soutien
et elle devait faire quoi  elle devait faire pour
gagner de l'argent et
souvent c'était des choses qui étaient de
l'autre côté de la loi,
elle avait toujours mon dos je ne lui ai jamais
parlé d'enfants se penchant hors de leurs voitures et
comme me criant [ __ ]
ou comme des enfants noirs j'étais  pas assez noir
pour w  frapper les enfants je n'étais pas
blanc donc je me suis battu deux fois plus nous vivions
dans toutes sortes d'états et de pays et
puis je suis allé à l'armée
j'ai été réprimandé et j'ai eu l'impression d'être
moins
et beaucoup de préjugés raciaux et de
stéréotypes
même dans  l'armée l'armée de l'air
comme si je n'avais jamais eu ma communauté
et je l'ai toujours voulu et puis ouais
colorer l'eau
j'étais
comme pas moyen j'étais comme pas moyen quelque chose doit
donner
et puis moi et david avions comme un très
terre-à-terre  parler
et il était comme nah mec comme si c'était une
famille
euh c'est comme si tu étais en sécurité ici c'était
cool
euh désolé oh c'est émotif mais euh
alors ouais ça a été comme vraiment une guérison je
pense que tous mes traumatismes
m'amènent à toutes ces choses mais  alors
quand je suis comme dedans
ouais j'aime la partie que
j'aime vraiment, c'est que
je ne pense à rien de tout cela qui est
la belle partie ouais c'est le
champ de fusée qui vous amène à cette destination
comme ça arrive  moi à la vague mais quand je suis
dans la vague ou je suis sous l'eau comme
m  Votre partie préférée de l'adrénaline
est que
je ne peux penser à rien d'autre.
Le but ultime pour nous est de
pouvoir créer une institution durable, d'
avoir de l'espace sur la côte et de pouvoir
offrir
des cours de surf gratuits à toutes les personnes de
couleur qui le souhaitent.  pour apprendre,
je veux dire que la croissance de cette communauté a
vraiment été incroyable
et donc pour la première fois de ma vie,
je me suis retrouvé dans l'eau avec vous
savez entouré de
tous ces corps noirs et bruns et ce
fut une expérience vraiment spéciale
que
j'adore  c'est maintenant parce que c'est comme si vous saviez que
nous jouions la musique que nous aimons
rouler ici et occupons vraiment l'
espace que vous savez et
ne vous sentez pas comme euh l'autre ici, mais
vous savez que nous avons tous le soutien
que nous pouvons  essayer ces nouvelles choses et
tomber
cette communauté est comme une chance d'être
vraiment
juste ici pour se présenter et prendre de la place
j'ai mes frères et sœurs avec moi
nous tous ensemble nous sommes si puissants
je suis à la mode depuis 20 ans
en plus d'avoir  g ma propre collection, j'ai
fait
et travaillé pour toutes les grandes marques, la
plupart des combinaisons pour ces grandes
entreprises,
ils prennent des combinaisons pour hommes, puis ils les
réduisent aux femmes, je pense que c'est
ce qui m'a déclenché,
d'accord, je vais faire mes propres combinaisons
merde toutes ces conneries
je vous promets qu'il n'y aura des
femmes asiatiques brunes à la peau foncée que
dans mes campagnes juste pour faire une déclaration
que nous appartenons à l'eau parce que c'est
presque comme si ces campagnes disaient aux
jeunes filles noires et brunes que vous n'appartenez pas
à  cet espace,
donc nous allons changer cela en faisant
ces combinaisons,
ce n'est pas à propos de moi, c'est à propos de cette
représentation
qui fera vibrer cette énergie à cette
jeune fille brune
qui voit quelqu'un dans mon costume et dit d'
accord
ces belles femmes brunes le font
je '  je suis censé ou pourrait le faire aussi,
donc c'est plus grand que moi
où d'autres personnes pourraient hésiter
parce qu'elles ne voient pas la représentation,
c'est comme si
je suppose que je suis différent de celui où
je suis têtu
et je suis juste lik  e si vous dites que je ne peux pas le faire,
cela me donne envie d'
essayer encore plus et alors juste vous savez être
cette représentation
peut-être que je ne vais pas être vous savez la meilleure
personne de couleur ou
afro-américaine vous savez que ça va
être un  surfeur mais peut-être que
tu sais peut-être que mon fils sera tu sais
peut-être que l'ami de mon fils sera
tu ne sais jamais pour qui tu peux être un
exemple et ça m'excite aussi
tu sais que ce n'est peut-être pas le jour dans
dix ans  sais parce que
je vais surfer pour toujours donc
quelqu'un va me voir et je suis tu sais que
je suis content d'être là pour eux
quand je suis là-bas c'est comme la forme la plus
pure de méditation
comme si c'était si fort mais au  en même temps,
c'est si calme,
tout ce que vous pouvez entendre, c'est l'océan et comme
tous vos problèmes s'estompent
pendant le temps que vous êtes dans l'eau,
c'est comme vous et les vagues
et quand elles vous emportent et que vous
vous effondrez
juste  comme se
détendre complètement et laisser l'eau faire ce
qu'elle fait
[Musique]
mon cœur est un  t paix et comme
pour ces quelques instants je suis juste comme si
[Musique]
heureux que
tu sois